hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to yandere simulator
now we've got some updates in this game
it's an entirely new game engine from
unity form to unity 5 but again you guys
don't care about those small
insignificant details when it comes to
the logs very feeling my heart for
senpai nothing else really matters but
what I do know is that in this build
there have been some bug fixes which
just means that open I get new and
interesting ways to get rid of sin pies
enemies and I want to get you
overwhelmed by the amazing glory that is
senpai to early in this video no there's
work to be done because believe it or
not there are scoundrels and basic
[ __ ] that want a piece of the senpai
pie and I will not share my senpai so we
have to dispatch of them in ways that
only we know and I think you know
exactly the way that I'm going to be
dispatching boobs McKenzie first because
last time I was oh but not this time not
on this beautiful day
not on this glorious morn of which I
will love senpai for all my life and all
eternity and we believe together forever
so how about you join me for a journey a
wonderful journey of lava
and just and murder a little bit of
murder a little bit of murder anyway
riding on the winds blow ah yes
dumbbells great dumbbells which remind
me of my enemies those that would thwart
me from survive
ah one dumbbell for the only lover
that's my needs in his life better be me
too for the perfect couple on campus the
most beautiful and adorable one that
everyone talks about three four as in
Three's Company and there shouldn't be
three when it comes to me and senpai so
you got a brush I'm over the head with a
dumbbell book four for the number of
holes I'm gonna put in the face of
anybody who looks and buys way and five
for the number of children that I'm
gonna give sent by when we're finally
married you all know about this you all
know what's about that
you know I'll know what I tried to do
but I don't know if it's gonna work
because oh they seem to have fixed my
leg oh that was bothering me a whole lot
last time well okay that's good to know
that's good to know
this game has been updated and actually
it runs a bit more smoothly now which is
awfully nice but hopefully they have
solved this problem this conundrum of
the balcony this little weirdness as we
are in the city that is floating on top
of the sky for some reason but I'm gonna
overlook that fact I've only got eyes
for senpai it it doesn't matter if we're
in the Klaus oh no no no it only matters
if Mike
for senpai can be felt through my
actions and the actions of which I speak
are the ones where I drop this dumbbell
said undercooked Igbo boobs Mackenzie's
and then she you go splat splat and then
she go bye-bye and nobody see for
him/her again she goes she bet gonna
wait now there's one thing I learned and
yandere simulator it's patience patience
to wait here for half an hour without
moving a single muscle while waiting for
my opportunit to present herself off
this balcony Oh only if she dared to
actually think about senpai which I
don't think that she's gonna work bombs
away
whoopsie it can't be no it can't be
no it can't be I don't think it is this
is a tragedy why would anyone do this
I'll call the police immediately
oh I've been a death academi High School
we need help right away
huh does this help wait teacher does
this help ten bye where are you gonna
send senpai senpai
what was that said bye no I'm gonna
sweep this up with the body go we're at
the body go with the bunny go teacher
does this help teacher am i helping if I
do it faster does it help it's a help
more yeah dieter I've got no one else to
impress but you send by red way does
that mean there's a body over here so
what happened oh my god why is she there
why is she why is she there
well better quick hey hey wake up wake
up point point
wait hey boobs McKenzie come on wake up
God it was just a prank bro it was just
a prank
well come on it was just a prank bro
idiots over here don't know what a prank
is
Hey oh yeah cowering in fear I know I
know that feeling
oh and so scared we're all scared we're
all scared here together
why I felt scared Wow fear is flowing
through my blood I'm scared you're
scared we're all scared
you need some out there who are your
knees oh oh police have arrived at
school
the police discover the corpse of Kona
Haruka that's not her name use a proper
name the police are unable to locate any
murder weapons the police questioned Yan
dairy Chan but can't hunt link her to
any crimes Hey I was trying to help all
right Emma
I was trying to mop up the blood if you
noticed I was mopping up the blood real
good it ah
please didn't have enough evidence to
perform an arrest the police
investigation ends and the students are
free to leave
well how handy-dandy that do all right I
guess we're good then you never change
stock sent by until he's returned safely
home and then returns to her own oh yeah
that would easily well well good for me
time to go rest but we're a no for a new
day where's that bite doesn't love
anybody else but me senpai do you
unloved me today is today the day that
we are going to be together forever and
this day that today is never ends coz
we're together forever is that the day
that today is time bye oh it's a little
dreary er today did people die you smell
so good today it's not good every day I
know ah
do you even know I'm here Oh giggle a
girl who haha
oh do you get my girl aid giggles I'm so
girly and charming you like that right
what are you like I'll be that thing you
all know that's not why we're really
here we're here for so much more than
that well exactly one more thing more
than that because we're here to dispatch
our arrival in a way that we weren't
trying and failing to do last time
oh no no no today is a very special day
and there's a very special thing to be
able to do on the today that it is oh
yes oh yes you get a double feature of
dispatch meant step number one go Danah
pocket this is the wrong place here we
go Oh dad fill it with water magical
water you didn't even need to bend over
to do that man when you got your bucket
water go take it to the science lab
wherever the hell that is I think it's
on the third floor oh there it is Oh
convenient oh good you got your
unsaleable bucket of water and you got a
screwdriver handy dandy tools for your
everyday you need school girl life with
murder then you go over here please
dance your way down this hallway and you
go over and visit your friendly
neighborhood boobs McKenzie who is oddly
enough alive ha ha ha ha how did you get
alive again I wish I could know that Oh
what do you think of sand pie oh you
don't know that is all good for you but
don't be insulting about it come on give
me your honest opinion about him what do
you think of sent by huh don't say he's
do handsome or else I'll kill you but
also don't say he's ugly around the hall
kill you for insulting you
that's best if you just all shut up and
don't do anything Wow boobs McKenzie do
you have any place to be now
do you have any place that you might
want to go to with your stupid boobs and
stupid hair place that you might want to
uh no I don't know conveniently go maybe
create some happenstance for you to be
dispatched anything like that you want
to go for that
well she's off like a gun where'd you go
Oh boobs II oh we're going Oh No Oh let
me follow you from a safe distance oh go
to the bathroom hey oh you are oh no oh
no oh okay I mean that's good for you
what could go wrong in arguably nothing
oh yeah you stay in there I'm going to
unscrew this I'm going to RQ this again
I'm going to I don't know I don't know
why someone would do this but I'm gonna
squeak squawk over here twice if you're
okay blink twice if you still love
senpai okay all right then let's go save
that for my collection I guess my weird
horrible murder collection haha but
anyway oh that was an eventful bathroom
trip for not me and someone else oh well
there's no one gonna notice this what
happens go to class
bye you know how these bathrooms are to
go in one comes out it's the [ __ ]
Hunger Games in there what can you know
about class oh my me just standing on
the desk here to attend class without
disposing a corpse while walking around
school a teacher discovers a corpse
teacher immediately calls the police
teacher for services balcony oh this
seems bad police investigation okay
please sir oh please determine the
kikuna Haruka again not her name died
from being electrocuted the police treat
her death as a possible murder and the
search and search the school for any
other victims the police are unable to
locate any corpses on school except for
that one you know that one corpse they
weren't able to find any other
you know unable to falow Kate any murder
weapons the police questioned yon dairy
Chan's that cannot link her to any
crimes
the police do not have enough evidence
to perform an arrest the police
investigation ends and the students are
free to leave thought that oh let me
rest my weary head dreams of that's
twice in one video McKenzie I didn't
know that it was gonna be such a
slaughter here but maybe I could just
finish it all off well where's the
button for the costume menu hmm whatever
they have blade hair mode
[Music]
is this what I think it is water not
another better than at any bearded in an
iterative okay so didn't do what I
thought it was gonna do I thought it was
exhaust lice people up no but apparently
not yeah yeah yeah that did that oh that
did the death tornado job no notices
this [ __ ] Wow same play almost got
caught up in the blast you're stepping
over the bodies I'm sorry
yeah I'm sorry well well well well I'm
because the legs
[Music]
everything about that huh
excuse me hi you're still standing oh my
god that's oh my god Zen bye don't look
over your shoulder it's bad news over
there
all right let's reset this nightmare oh
there's a fever dream everything's back
to normal
ah good okay so we can end this with
things not being so unbelievably
terrible so thank you everybody so much
for watching there are more things in
this version of the game to explore more
Easter eggs more ways to illuminate your
rival more stuff in general so if you
know what you want me to do didn't write
it down in the comments below give me a
suggestion you know I may take it I may
not but otherwise let me know how I did
in comments below let me know what you
think is Empire but you know what'll
happen if you answer sleep wrong so
thank you again and as always I will see
you
[Music]